[Music]
in Titanic tours news hi tagging Oh help
me and will Leonardo carabiner Leo this
is the capital [ __ ] okay how each other
who that the business by Marwa from
Tunisia to me young a night in Tunisia a
tour company is booking trips to explore
the world's most famous shipwreck Oh
anything that involves underwater
exploration
count me the [ __ ] in yo I thought you
said you're scared of the ocean
uh yeah I'm scared if it's just my body
if it's just my body in there I'm like
oh [ __ ] I can't send for myself -
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that's way crazy
me but if I'm gonna encapsulate it like
a glass of marine spin on town
yeah like let me be say let me feel sane
there's a london-based tour company that
has announced that there will be having
tourists go visit the Titanic where did
it sink really it's in the middle of the
Atlantic okay in literally in the middle
okay no they took a [ __ ] measuring
tape and I went from talking to East
Coast and I measured it all the way to
whether something point is and they
measured it all the way to the [ __ ]
way London yes it is london-based tour
company they ventured both announced
that they're going to be booking tours
now for 2018 but these tours are booked
in expense for many money look if you
guys want to get a room 130 thousand
what 40,000 any other guesses I'm
thinking five thousand my daughter's
name is 330 thousand kidney doesn't I
said [ __ ] expensive Oh fifteen
dollars my [ __ ] expensive in life or
[ __ ] expensive and I'll shake it
ah to a ticket I got and in life it's
really expensive
Oh 572 million dollar you know you're
getting two people it's going to be
awkward I'll be gone or according to the
ticket yeah just tell you the frickin
price yeah
one hundred and five thousand dollars
and doing five thousand dollars a lot of
money $100,000 dollars a hundred five
one hundred and five thousand dollars
yeah
what an odd number to to charge god damn
well the exact number is a hundred and
five thousand one hundred and twenty
nine dollars I'm so specific very good
so it's [ __ ] six figures to go here
yes and the reason why it's so specific
is that this has been adjusted for
inflation so it actually it's actually
the price of a first-class ticket on the
Titanic back in nineteen well Wow so
when you were going on a Titanic and
when Leo nodded appreciate went on there
he was really lucky that he won that
take really lucky Wow oh wait so
first-class ticket back then was like a
hundred thousand dollars in today's
dollars
Wow that's crazy because I remember the
conversation to what he was sitting at
the table in the dinners and he was
talking about life he that hits me even
more now yeah yeah [ __ ] boat for the
hall I don't know any [ __ ] ticket
today that cost $100,000 how do you get
there
okay so first what they're saying is
that the triple began with a helicopter
ride from st. John's which is a city on
the island of Newfoundland Canada
enables out wear long johns was invented
but they will take you to a yacht that
station near the Titanic's resting place
and then so this entire tour it's an
eight-day journey and they will only be
taking nine people at a time oh and
they're saying that so each day they'll
have like different they'll be focusing
on different things I'm not sure how
many times we'll be diving down to the
three Titanic's but they did mention
that it takes two hours to get to go
down and two hours to come back holy
[ __ ] got scary boy so you are you in
scuba gear you go down a submarine now
so you'll be going down and this
submersible session looks stupid it
cannot
uh-uh weird I mom no cool take me I
don't want to ride in something like
that
I'm ground yeah that's kind of scary get
no [ __ ] mermaid [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
no way somebody take me please I just
see like a giant squid coming I know
girl with you with that but this me
personally I don't think I could do it
how many hours it takes two hours right
word you [ __ ] and piss if you got to go
I don't know I think you have to hold it
I can own it for two hours and four
hours I'll agree fine I won't eat it it
would be five hours four hours just
traveling that's not including enjoying
the same that I that lowers down floor
talk yeah six hours down to like explore
is almost cool I want to see a better
submarine that [ __ ] looks like an
eyeball with a thin is it the aesthetic
steps pissing you off
or you just is it something else I don't
know any guy that could get [ __ ] in a
Mini Cooper you know uh uh you know what
would be really [ __ ] cool though like
you know like because we're like trying
to go like from like custom poster stuff
only in the air what if we had like a
submarine that we just go straight to
the [ __ ] water that was faster than
going to there and impossible impossible
because too much get tons of air in the
night is that what this is way too much
friction and water yeah that's what it
is yeah [ __ ] idea what you need is
like those Bank air to get I go under
the water and then you just constantly
hmm and then you when your car code yeah
I can find any Melissa
no no he's Australian current I thought
there was concepts about that already
though like traveling they always got
contracts by nobody doing you want
trying to copy my ideas but they don't
do it right mm-hmm
they don't know it right traveling is
like the key yeah sir saying that these
tours will begin me 2018 ah Christmas
present guys who you putting it out
there $100,000 in a burst your bubble
right now because they're saying that
they've all been blown out whoa
and there's already got many balls out
there what if it's like nine mainlanders
oh I'll be soaked you I'll be so pissed
if I could afford it right and I'm the
one that's there but then there's me and
eight other mainlanders I'd be so bad
and piston inside the submarine you know
what's up being a part of this tour it's
pretty awesome because you're also being
a part of a larger scientific study so
what they're saying is that these
tourists that will serve as mission
specialists and they will be able to log
3d images and help like further awesome
so they're actually paying for the site
to further scientific studies okay yeah
and I thought I actually think that
these funds that these uh what thing it
just keeps all back and he picked his
own screaming yes the funds that they're
paying for these tours they're funding
this scientific studies oh my god that's
why it costs money this was science but
they did mention that during this entire
like you know this all these days that
they will be offering deep-sea diving
orientation and things like that and
then so they can also learn how to take
these 3d images you'll be learning a lot
and you'll also be learning home
reaching yeah you'll be learning about
the workings of the ship and just marine
life down there because it's like 13,000
oh god I so cool I wanna be scuba
certified yeah me too you know I was so
bummed out when I went to Cancun we pay
for the thing everything was set to go
we did the training in the swimming pool
and then they tell us that the boat
doesn't work and then we couldn't go out
in the ocean I'll fill them out the
ocean scares me though especially at
night yeah man
he's like a floating order tonight all
the time in the ocean and the deep sea
it isn't life it's always night down
there yeah down look that I just like
the coral sighs yeah shallow colorful
fun Finding Nemo Society sometimes to
like it freaked out by those parrotfish
that are the size of this [ __ ]
reflector in front of us like this big
yeah they're kind of nasty oh you
[ __ ] yeah just crushing rock and [ __ ]
you know what the there
a lot of critics against these tourists
so they're saying that it's just this
capable of the fact that you know 15 or
1,500 people died in that ship and
you're just going there and they must
hate Pearl Harbor they must hate ya
everything they just follow that movie
Titanic and they're emotionally attached
to it
punk-ass [ __ ] you know you can't they
can't afford a hundred thousand so
they're [ __ ] salty yeah hi guys hope
that was an insightful episode of
Jessica D news please stay close to
every single person in this video by
cruising on over to the description box
and following us on Instagram for more
videos click right over here
[Music]